Speaker 1: All right. Why don't we speak next
to. You know, there's just so many people
waiting today. What if we speak to Ryan from
Austin? Ryan from Austin, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 3: I just had a quick question. What do
you think the Democrats messaging should be going
into the upcoming midterms, given the current
political landscape? Do you think that gun control
and abortion rights are going to be winning
issues in November? Or do you think we should
have a more like broad, progressive message?
Speaker 1: You know, 99% of the time I would
be saying abortion and gun rights are not
winning issues and it should be primarily
an economic message. We are in a unique
situation where I'm actually wondering
maybe the focus should be on the right's
determined inaction on gun issues and its support
of the overturning of Roe v Wade by the Supreme
Court, which is very unpopular with the American
public. And I would almost never say this. Every
election I've covered, I have not not said this.
Don't talk about guns. Don't talk
about abortion. This particular time,
the public seems so repulsed with what's going
on with those two issues. What the hell? Maybe
it is a good strategy this November.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I agree. The only thing
I worry about is I wonder if that public
repulsion is going to continue to be there
in November or if it's going to fall away.
Speaker 1: It's still five months from now,
and who knows what will happen in the next five
months. That's my hesitation as well. But I think
compared to other elections, it actually might be
a winning message this time around. I don't know.
And listen, you know what? Otherwise,
it's not like it was looking that great
for Democrats anyway. So I don't know
that I have a better idea for them.
Speaker 3: Yeah, exactly what the
hell means. We'll run on it. Yeah.
All right. Well, thank you so much.
Speaker 1: Okay. Thanks for the call. We're going
to keep taking calls after a very short break.
So please don't hang up. I will get right back
to the phones in a moment. Okay. Let's get back to
people waiting to chat on discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. Let's go next to our friend
Isa from London. Isa, welcome back to the program.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Speaker 2: Um, you know, I was thinking that loads
of gun owners in the US, they say that one of the
reasons they want to own weapons is to protect
themselves from an overly intrusive government.
Yes, like a tyrannical government. Um, so I don't
know too much about this, but I was wondering if,
say, if the US government decided to, uh, like,
launch an attack on this population, wouldn't
they use military technology? That, that would be,
it would be meaningless to use rifles against that
kind of stuff.
Speaker 1:
That's my opinion as well. Yeah. And this has been
brought up before, which is if the you know, and
it's funny because many of the same people that
say that love having the biggest, most powerful
military. So they simultaneously are like, we need
our military to have all the best, most powerful
stuff. And also, if it becomes tyrannical, we need
to have our assault rifles to protect ourselves.
Which, number one, wouldn't really even
be useful because the government has such
overwhelming force. But also, if you suspect that
that may happen with the government, why would you
want them to
have such a powerful army like it's both idiotic
and also contradictory? It doesn't make any sense.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah, good point.
I agree. I think it's, um, it's a
bit odd how, uh, loads of American gun owners feel
like, uh, their sense of freedom is, is tied into
being able to own firearms.
Speaker 1: Yes. And not only their sense
of freedom. Their sense of identity.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right. Well,
thank you very much for the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
There's Isa from London. Always great to hear
from our friends on the other side of the pond